ma mère elle en avait pas de vacance de
style mon père non plus et puis c'est
pour ça qu'ils disent qu'on a de la
chance qui n'est pas allé au moins une
fois en classe de neige
cette initiative est née dans les années
1950 un médecin scolaire
max fourestier à l'idée d'un mi-temps
pédagogique et sportif à la montagne
l'éducation nationale approuve le projet
et en 1953 pour la première fois
trente-cinq élèves d'une école de vente
partait dans les halles
après une matinée consacrée au travail
scolaire les écoliers dispose de tout
leur après-midi pour s'initier au ski
sur les pentes des alpes
une nouvelle formule efficace et ont
déjà en mesure d'affirmer
l'expérimentation est un succès très
vite les classes de neige se généralise
en france
les classes de neige ont quatre ans en
1950 points une seule classe à tenter
l'expérience cette année 5000 écoliers
comme ceux là ont quitté paris pour
respirer pendant un mois l'air de la
montagne quitter la ville et respirer
l'air de la montagne ça donne envie
alors qu il n'est pas possible de partir
avec ses copains forcément ça fait des
déçus jambes alors pourquoi toi tu n'y
vas pas je ne veux pas et tu sais
pourquoi ne peux pas c'est parce que
jamais laissé partir tout seul
aujourd'hui la pratique du ski s'est
démocratisée mais à l'époque les classes
de neige c'était l'occasion de dévaler
les pistes et à chacun sa technique et
moi tu pourrait m'expliquer un petit peu
par exemple comment on remonte une pente
avec lescure au mais les skis parallèles
et puis au on monte un escalier on monte
un escalier c'est à dire mais parallèles
et puis les jeunes élèves ne sont pas
les seuls à profiter des classes de
neige l'économie montagnarde en
bénéficient aussi
comme en témoigné ce patron de bar en
1961 ça vous permet d'occuper du
personnel personnel du pays c'est
l'hiver et ne travaille par ailleurs
alors là il peut donner un coup de main
ils le font d'ailleurs très volontiers
quand tu vois et courir tout ce qu'il
appelle les classes de neige sont moins
populaires aujourd'hui selon le conseil
national du tourisme
leur nombre s'est effondrée depuis les
années 90 première cause le coût du
séjour
[Musique]